stop Gordon looks like it's like we got
two beards in the room three if you
can't your wife let's dive in first
question why is such a couple I'm
kidding I'm totally I'm kidding that's
the second question I skipped ahead
let's get to the heart of the matter now
why can't you be like other actors good
ones speed round answer as quickly as
you can
now if you had a gun to your head do you
consider Deadpool the Green Lantern of
good movies
what's Eva Mendes like I don't know
what's Blake Lively like she's wonderful
now what's Blake Lively like you're can
pick right now what made Deadpool so
successful well it's a combination of
things I mean you've got the great
director at Tim Miller you have
incredible writers and ret reason so
Lord right now I don't even know if I'm
paying so GQ Man of the Year that's a
big honor you know I can't I can't think
of anyone more worthy yeah well it's uh
hey Jake see you there
what's he doing you know what are you
doing here but we just cut the cameras
for just one second hey how many times
have you met your children what are you
talking about I seen your kids every
single day and night the cameras aren't
rolling yes they are and even if they
run why such a good guy already asked
that question hold on okay of all the
endangered animals that you've eaten
which one would you say tastes best
I've never you're right the American
bald eagle is off the endangered species
list if I don't think it is well at
least you admit to eating one I think I
think we're done here
stop stop it don't don't butter nut
butter not now clamp bring it about
girls yeah that does it I'm done here I
love you
[Music]